I'll tell you this love bees you should
have won every Hey
yes I have been I know you have a note
oh yes sorry yes it's sort of like the
way you have a show yes I do a briefing
you have formal prime time I have Cuomo
all the time it's the cute brotherly
moments like that that has America
totally swooning over the Cuomo brothers
you know it's not like you've been
cutting your own hair which Chris and
Andrew Cuomo have been in the public eye
a whole lot more since the corona virus
outbreak started my brother Christopher
as I told you yesterday tested positive
for the corona virus he's at home Chris
who tested positive for Koba 19 last
month is still hosting his CNN show
Cuomo primetime from home and he
frequently interviews his big brother
who is the governor of New York people
will be remembered for how they stepped
up right now and what they did what they
didn't do and I'm very proud of you big
bro
yeah we joke a lot but the strength that
you showed here and the dedication to
journalism and your skill and your
ability to make this okay for people and
to communicate it why don't you I love
you I've always been proud of you but
I've never been prouder of you than I am
right now yeah they have been all kinds
of cute and America is freaking loving
it now a source close to Chris tell ziti
the brothers are aware of the Cuomo
crush and hashtag Cuomo brothers they
think it's cute and playful we're
talking about my my brother talking
about my little brother this is my best
friend the source jokingly adds quote
although Chris doesn't understand why
people think Andrew is so handsome my
pop would be proud
I love you little brother and even
though this isn't a flattering picture
I did not pick this picture with your
mouth open but it is suitable in some
ways and despite the Internet's
obsession with them they're not letting
the hype distract them from their work
both brothers know the responsibilities
they have during this global crisis and
they take their job seriously
chris has lighthearted moments during
interviews with his brother but isn't
afraid to ask him tough questions and
holds him accountable they both respect
what the other does and both are
extremely proud of one another despite
the ribbing he found out yesterday
morning that he had coronavirus he did
his show last night he did a show last
night from his basement what a gutsy
courageous thing to do Chris is still
recovering from the virus at his home in
Long Island and one of my all-time
favorite Cuomo brother moments went down
when Chris was explaining the
hallucinations that he had due to his
high fever you came to me in agreement
you had on a very interesting and you
were dancing in the dream and you were
waving a wand and saying I wish I could
wave my wand and make this go away and
then you spun around and you danced away
the look on Andrews face though well
that's a there's a lot of a metaphorical
reality now I thank you for sharing that
with us kind of use obviously obviously
the fever has affected your mental
capacity and yeah and I'll leave you
with this I know you're working hard for
your state but no matter how hard you're
working there's always time to call mom
she wants to hear from you just so you
know yeah I called mom
I called mom and that was where I came
on this show it's not what I the way she
said I was her favorite she never said
good news is she said you were her
second favorite second favorite son
Christopher